good morning everyone
um before we start if we could please
rise and join me in the Pledge of
Allegiance
of the United States of America and to
the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible with
thank you at this point I'm opening the
full committee work session
to deal with HB 287 and hb470
and
representative Muse would you like to
talk to us for a few seconds here about
this
but
these are these are two bills uh that uh
earlier on the schedule we decided to uh
to hold off on uh execing and um uh one
of the things that that has done is it
has given us some time uh to basically
put together some information that
compares and contrasts uh two bills that
that I sent I think essentially try to
achieve the same aims
um one of the things that we're trying
to do right now in New Hampshire
is to catch up to where some other
states are in terms of our ability
to legally offer drug checking and and
why drug checking is important is
because of the amount of uh of uh of
fentanyl that's being found in in pills
that are actually being sold on the
street
any more fentanyl is being used to to
cut other drugs because it's cheaper
than those drugs it's more available
than those drugs and I think one of the
things we're finding out in New
Hampshire is it's also far more deadly
than those drugs
so I think our choice to today hopefully
it's it's it and we we kind of go in uh
one of uh one of two directions but
basically go in the same general
direction of catching up
but but I think the the the ultimate
goal here of of both of these bills is
to reduce the number of deaths due to
overdose uh in this state
um we have a real issue
um my personal opinion is that one of
the bills will go farther and will help
us do that and will help us
um will help us save more lives
the other bill would be a good start
but one of the things that I would I
would ask you to sort of keep in the
back of your mind as you as you look at
look at both of these bills is
the severity of the problem that we have
now so not too long ago I read on in the
news that five people died of overdoses
in a single week in Manchester alone
so we have uh we have a real problem and
and well I'll be the first to admit that
we we absolutely need to uh
put resources uh into law enforcement
and Border interdiction and start
stopping uh you know the flow of drugs
into New Hampshire
um what it doesn't do is change the fact
that there are already a lot of drugs
that are already in New Hampshire and
are killing people
and so we we
know we I'd like to think that um this
isn't a choice between one approach or
the other that essentially the the basic
approach of reducing the harm that the
drugs that are already in our state can
do is something that we can adopt as a
strategy uh to complement
um the sort of tighter enforcement I
think that everybody wants to see
so essentially that's what
um HB 470 uh as uh as amended uh would
do uh to a lesser extent what 287 would
do is uh offer some protection to people
legal protection to people who are using
and providing fentanyl test strips now
which are which are basically currently
considered illegal drug paraphernalia
in in terms of what it might accomplish
one of the things that we learned during
the public hearing is we're we learned
that the test strips are already being
distributed in New Hampshire they're not
I wouldn't say that they're widely
available but they're available in in
some of the places where they actually
will do good
so you know an issue is is how far do we
do we actually want to go with this do
we want to catch up a little bit
um or do we want to lay the groundwork
for actually being able to do you know
to expand this type of work and one of
the reasons why this is necessary is
we're also seeing things like um like
xylazine being cut into drugs on the
street and uh while xylazine doesn't
create the same kind of Overdose
problems at the same level that cutting
pills with fentanyl does it creates a
whole other set of problems in terms of
the way that it reacts with some of the
drugs that it's combined with and also
just the physical toll that it takes on
the people who use it
I'm not an expert in Pharmacology but it
looks like using xylazine can create
some of the same physical effects that
we see with people who are on meth
open source uh open source that get
infected
it's it's
basically a terrible thing for anybody
to have to go through
um
so so I think one of the things we're
trying to do is to you know with with
this approach is to modify our
controlled Drug Act in a way that makes
it possible uh for us not only to
provide things like fentanyl test strips
but to provide more widespread uh the
more widespread capability for people
who are uh who are using uh you know who
are using drugs and yes they're they are
illegal drugs but for people who are
using these drugs to actually know what
they're taking and I think one of the
things that I said during the public
hearing that I'll uh that I'll repeat
now is
if it was your kid
you know what would you want
you know would you would you want us to
be would you want them I mean you're
never going to want them to take drugs
um but if they are taking drugs if
they're thinking about taking drugs
wouldn't you want to know that there's a
place you can go or they could go uh
just to make sure that what they're
taking is really what they think they're
taking and uh and also what they what
they to know that what they might take
um while not actually being you know
quote unquote safe at least won't kill
them uh so I think those are the things
that we're trying to accomplish today
one of the things that I've done is I've
I've uh in conjunction with some of the
folks who are here
Ms naughty Miss McGinley
um put together a uh a comparison sheet
between the two bills there is an
amendment to 470 that I'm prepared to
walk through but for now I'm gonna stop
talking and let other people lay in
thank you actually before you stop
talking
um could you just tell us the the change
you made in the amendment the the the
concern that we heard was regarding the
packaging materials for um
for controlled substances and it looks
like you've done something with it I'm
just not sure
you know the the the the concern around
packaging materials we have attempted to
address that in the amendment so so in
the original bill I think the way that
folks were interpreting it is that any
packaging materials would no longer you
know be subject uh you know uh for
instance if you're found with packaging
materials uh you know during an
investigation
um those actually couldn't be used in in
the prosecution
um and so the the you know the issue
with that I think uh from a law
enforcement point of point of view is
you you know you want to make sure that
people who are creating factories or who
are Distributing uh Distributing drugs
uh that materials like that can actually
be used as evidence in the prosecution
against them
um what we're trying to do with the
amendment is to sort of separate that
kind of packaging from essentially what
people would need to bring in a small
amount of drugs to get tested
so the little baggie that I use uh the
little sandwich bag that I use to to
bring in half of a pill or a small
amount of drugs
um we we don't necessarily want people
charged with violating the drug
paraphernalia law if they if for for
simply using that to package the
material that they want to have tested
so I think that's the distinction that
we're making another thing that we've
done with the amendment we've added uh
there's a provision in there that when
we're defining drug checking
um we're also uh expanding the um uh the
expanding it to cover not only naloxone
which is the opioid reversal agent
that's uh currently the most in use with
with fentanyl
overdoses as well as any kind of opioid
overdoses and just broadening it to
include all opioid reversal agents and
one of the reasons we're doing that is
because the FDA has actually begun to
approve some new opioid reversal agents
that will be more effective on fentanyl
so a in a state where where so often
trying to catch up
one of the things that we're we're
trying to do is is catch up a little
more if not start to get a little bit
ahead of the game or at least put
ourselves into a position where every
time we do something like this we don't
have to start from scratch and to to to
do things like add things like fentanyl
test strips one bill at a time
all right representative thank you I'm
looking at the amendment and it says I'm
confused and it may be just me but
paragraph x a
says drug paraphernalia will include
packaging repackaging storing but then
the addition underneath says it shall
not include drugs
um packaging preparing so how does that
how does that address the law
enforcement concern I think I think what
if you look down at XD if you look at
the last line in XD
um uh what it says is drug packaging in
this section refers to packaging
materials provided for or utilized in
drug checking okay
thank you
anywhere else now I represent Manion
thank you Mr chairman
I'm looking at the section that says
nominal containing nominal amounts for
the purpose of checking the definition
being 10 milligrams or less is this does
this bill make possessing 10 milligrams
that's all that's how I'm reading it so
you can help me out with that what it
what it does is it considers 10
milligrams or less when it is when it is
brought in for drug checking
um what it what what it does is make it
allowable for for drug checking it
doesn't make the drug legal
um but uh if if it's being brought in
for drug checking purposes
uh a nominal and essentially what what
it the reason that's in there is people
have to bring in something
and given the nature of the Beast
anything that they bring in is going to
be illegal
um so I mean we're it's a little bit of
a conundrum and this is an area where we
do need to have a little bit of
thank you Mr chairman this was a
follow-up so if if people who use drugs
package it all in 10 milligram
increments
and anytime they get stopped they can
say they're on the way to get it tested
would that pose a problem would that
I think one of the thing one of the so I
I'm not sure you're I'm not sure I uh I
understand the premise of your question
but the women I think I think what he's
saying is if I'm a drug dealer and I
want to circum nut make it circumvent
the law
can I then just package everything in 10
milligram packages and if I get stopped
say I'm just going to have a check at
the place with this law let me on
so if you
so kind of following that through if if
you have 10 milligrams uh and it's in
the type of packaging that somebody
would normally use uh the average person
um would use uh to to actually transport
a small amount of drugs to a drug
testing facility yes
um somebody somebody could say somebody
could say that on the other hand what
you what they wouldn't be able to do is
to create a whole bunch of little tiny
packages with less than 10 milligrams uh
and if you if you stop them they they
wouldn't be able to say oh you know I
only have a whole bunch of little tiny
packages and I'm on my way to drug
checking I mean I mean this is
I think part part of what we're trying
to do here is we're we're trying to help
people who otherwise
might die from taking drugs that
basically have bad stuff in them
um we're not trying to get in the way of
criminal prosecutions at all and I but I
think these are science some of the
Judgment calls that we have to be
willing to make if we're gonna if we're
going to save more lives in this state
I I agree I just I think that when we
look at these we also have to play
Devil's Advocate to make sure that we
don't we don't leave a a big hole um
but I see where you're going who had to
I've been here 120 seconds and I want to
talk I just had a question for president
Manion because um or maybe any other
people with law enforcement experience
in the room
um I know that there's some inferences
or at least as I as far as I know
there's some inferences that you have to
make to decide between the charge of
possession or versus possession with
intent to distribute do I have that
right and I was thinking that maybe if
you can speak to the reasoning between
one of those charges or the other that
that might highlight how this would be
implemented or like shed some light on
it
yes clearly there's you need more to
prove dealing as opposed to just
possessing however my question goes both
ways if I'm a drug user and I know that
10 million 10 milligrams or less is
legal that's all I'm going to carry on
me at any given time or that's how I'm
going to package it and I'm not talking
just specifically dealers this applies
to anything
so if you're a drug user and you want to
skirt the system you just package
everything in 10 milligrams or less and
now it's legal to possess that's my
concern
well that's what I'm trying to
understand I'm not asking this question
and to be argumentative but to
understand because I've never had to
personally decide between
charging someone with possession versus
possession with intent to distribute but
it is possible from what I understand
for someone to have a substantial volume
of illegal drugs that they don't intend
to distribute and then there's whatever
factors are observed by the officer that
seem to justify the charge of possession
with intent to distribute and so I
wonder if someone had a whole bunch of
10 milligram packages
why couldn't they be charged with intent
to distribute in that case you know AB
like regard regardless of whatever the
law says that so that's what I'm trying
to wrap my head around is like when does
an officer decide yeah that is to
distribute that is one of the elements
that would go towards intent to
distribute packaging material the amount
of the uh a drug if the drugs
pre-packaged
um a lot of money there's a lot of
different things that would add up to an
intent to distribute having a lot of
packages would be one of the elements
um well that's what I mean is why
couldn't that be a charge in in such a
such a scenario if someone had a whole
bunch of 10 milligram or whatever
packages what what's the limitation I'm
guessing like that's what I guess I'm
trying to get at is like what would
prevent an officer from charging someone
with intent to distribute in that
in my experience
having let's say they had five bags each
one of them was 10 milligrams or less
that certainly would not be enough to
charge them with possession with intent
to distribute well you could probably
charge them but you wouldn't get a
conviction you would need other things
you you might need some history you
might need as as the chairman said a lot
of money in this possession maybe some
scales for weighing stuff extra
packaging equipment on the side you have
to have quite a bit to prove uh intent
to distribute I just think if if
somebody's if somebody packages up four
or five 10 milligram bags and they're in
their purse that's certainly not going
to be enough to charge with intend to
distribute my experience representative
Mandan what do you think though about
the last part of the sentence that says
containing normal amounts for the
purpose of drug checking I think that it
would be difficult to make the argument
if you had three or four bags that that
was just for drug checking don't you
think
clarity
I
I guess I'm not in support of legalizing
any amount of it I mean if you're gonna
if you're gonna test it I mean aren't
these testing strips something that a
person could get
I thought that was a point of these
fentanyl Tessa strips or or if there's
any new drugs coming along as the person
would actually could get the test strips
and test it on their own not have to
bring it somewhere to test it I just see
it opening up a door to people now being
creative with their packaging to get
around
drug possession charges
Earths and Roads
thank you Mr chairman
um
I don't know if this question is
necessary for representative Muse or if
it's representative Manion
the concern that I that I have with this
which I've always had
is
there's two sides of every coin right so
if you're a drug dealer
and your intention is to sell Fentanyl
would this just not make it a lot easier
to be able to show that indeed there is
the drug that you're looking for
in in this
so how do how
how do you how do you combat that
because every everybody is very creative
right
um that that is the concern that I have
so representative Mania kind of brought
it up and I
um
I think I would have to have that a
little bit more drastic what a what a
test strip would do is it would show
that fentanyl is is in whatever you're
testing what it wouldn't show is the
purity of the drug
um and it wouldn't necess it it wouldn't
necessarily it wouldn't show things like
uh like xylazine uh it wouldn't show uh
sometimes antidepressants or stimulants
or other things that can be mixed in a
pill right so if you're a dealer you
know trying to prove let's say that you
know this is the good the good stuff I
mean all of all the test strip will do
is show you that there's a little bit of
fentanyl in it it'll it'll be positive
it's kind of like a pregnancy test trip
where you can you know you're 100
pregnant
you know
so it's representative Muse I think that
you're
I think you are saying exactly what my
concern is is that if you are
selling it
this is going to show you that you are
indeed selling what you say you're
selling
well and actually if you if you kind of
think that through a little bit too I
mean a lot of one of the issues we have
is that people don't know they're buying
drugs with fentanyl in them
um so if it if a dealer actually was to
test it I mean part the a big part of
the issue is people just don't know what
they're taking you know and and that's
that's part of that's one of the reasons
why
uh why we're having so many issues with
overdosing right now
um so I I won't say that you know I I
wouldn't say that there isn't any
conceivable way that parts of this
process could conceivably help a drug
dealer a little tiny bit but there have
been there has been a lot of effort
um behind this bill to make sure that
what we're actually doing is maximizing
the harm that these drugs will you know
can do on people who don't understand
what they're taking that that's the real
focus of it
thank you I'd like to at this point
um I was wondering I see it as a
representative from the chiefs of the
Police Association here would you uh
based on what you've heard so far I'm
sure go ahead I mean
what was the reasoning or like what was
the basis
and actually I think I'll I'll let Miss
Nolte uh answer that question and I'm
going to ask them to come up after the
chief talk so okay
sure I think I actually know it but I
just want to make sure I have it 100
right thank you
thank you Mr chairman I just want to
clarify I'm in support of the testing
equipment to test these drugs and I want
to make sure everyone knows that I just
don't want to reach a point where we
legalize any amount of drugs that that
people become creative with and now
possession becomes an issue even not
even dealing just possession alone but I
am in support of testing or the ability
to test these things
go ahead Chief thank you
yes good morning members of the
committee and uh Mr chair thank you for
giving an opportunity to uh to address
some of these issues my name is John
perfonsky I'm the chief in Bedford and I
am the President of the Police
Association the Chiefs Association in
law enforcement is not opposed to
fentanyl test strips or testing
equipment as representative just
indicated uh we're not in opposition to
a fentanyl test strip or any material
that would determine whether or not
there is illicit or even listed drugs uh
in in a particular amount of drugs but
we are opposed to any provision that
would effectively legalize the
possession of any quantity of controlled
drugs that results in the death of
individuals
for those who may not be familiar with
fentanyl right fentanyl two micrograms
not milligrams micrograms of fentanyl
which
would sit on the top of Lincoln's head
on a penny is enough to kill someone so
we're we're definitely uh in adamantly
opposed to any legislation that would
legalize the possession of drugs uh of
any quantity that is lethal and can kill
people but we're not opposed to uh test
strips or other material that would
allow someone to determine whether or
not a particular quantity of a substance
contains a particular drug in it that
seems perfectly reasonable
and your colleagues across the way have
a complimentary bill that that does that
but it does not include the drugs that
are being tested themselves the notion
that people are going to travel to a
particular location unless there is
something that people are thinking about
in terms of setting up a storefront to
test drugs which I haven't heard of yet
it seems to me that people would be
testing
um would be getting test strips and if
they had the notion to test whatever
they had they would do that wherever
they were
uh so uh and let me also add that uh in
talking to people that are substance
abusers and users that have substance
abuse disorders that I've talked to over
44 years of law enforcement 27 and Drug
law enforcement
um some will tell you not all some will
tell you that they're actively seeking
drugs with fentanyl in it for the
particular purpose for why that drug is
in it it gives them a more euphoric
reaction
um than than other drugs and uh honestly
I don't want to and I don't hope that
the committee is not being misled that
drug checking or fentanyl test strips
will have a perceptible change in in the
drug deaths rate in the state of New
Hampshire 473 last year and we're on
trajectory to increase that this year
law enforcement desperately desperately
wants to reduce that number to zero if
at all possible there's been a lot of
money in treatment and Recovery which is
where it should be
and there is more opportunities for
treatment recovery than we've ever had
in the state which is a good thing
but we're swimming in a sea of illegal
drugs here in the state and people will
use those if they're available
and we desperately need some additional
coordination and support to be able to
reduce the supply of drugs that are
killing more than 470 Granite Staters
every year that's appalling to me as a
police chief and a law enforcement
professional and we are desperately
trying to find a way to reduce that
we're not opposed to drug checking but
please do not add the checking amount of
thank you chief
if there were because it's my
understanding that there are some places
or there will be some places where
people could go and have their stuff
checked
if that if if that were the case how
would we address the
um
the people going to have their stuff
tested would would there any change to
this I know that using a word such as
residual versus nominal would any of
that help you think or just leave it
alone as far as illegality
in a practical sense a law enforcement
officer is not going to be able to
determine someone that's taking a
quantity a testable amount of drugs and
there needs to be a testable amount
right to facilitate because clearly as
you indicated they're going to say oh
well I'm I'm going to the drug checking
facility right the same issue occurs
with the drug take-back boxes right
there were various iterations of uh take
back bill that would allow someone to
bring illicit drugs to a take back box
well right I get stopped by a trooper
and I have a kilo of heroin with me with
fentanyl in it well I'm going to take it
to the Dropbox facility right how are
you going to disprove that you can't in
a practical sense so you've created a
defensible argument to possession of
representative jambrian
thank you Mr chairman thank you Chief a
few questions if I may
um a police officer in the field I
remember I'm going back to the 1990s
when I was actively involved in that
profession
um come upon a scene and they find a
substance
and obviously you don't want to be
touching it as a police officer rubber
gloves the whole thing PPE how do you
test in the field whether there are
illicit drugs present and what drugs can
you presently test for
well it's been a while since I've done
that uh Mr representative so
um I'll tell you that the most recent
technology right which we don't have DEA
has it and they do make it available to
State Police and local Municipal it's
it's
um a sort of a
a device that allows
the operator to
analyze the the substance without
actually touching it right I haven't
used it so I'm not exactly sure how that
works test strips
um are particularly dicey when it comes
to fentanyl because if it becomes
Airborne in any kind of quantity if it
happens to be at a very high potency
rate it can induce an overdose and of
course you know we're all aware of law
enforcement officers and other folks
that have been um treated at hospitals
after succumbing to an overdose when a
quantity of material gets airborne right
and it's absorbable so
testing is usually done by strips or
placing a quantity and a tiny little
plastic bag mixing it with a reagent or
reagents in that bag and then
observing the color of the liquid that's
in the bag that determines whether or
not that particular substance for
methamphetamine and and other types of
drugs including heroin and whatnot
that's been the most common practice
over the years but there is new
technology out there that can do it it's
and chief just for the clarity of a
committee a positive test on the test
kit would was that probable cause to
arrest at that point
uh it gives you a presumptive indication
that there's a presence of illicit drugs
right
um and then the sample or the quantity
would then have to be sent to the state
forensic lab to be subject to a higher
level of tests with a gas chromat
chromatographer
big machine to test to make sure that it
representative Newman
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
so if someone has a pill that they don't
know what's in it
and they bring a portion that has 10
milligrams in it to wherever or they get
stopped or it is tested
with the method you you indicated
it would tell you there could be any
number of illicit drugs is there's there
are limited how much can it tell you
about that other than there's an illicit
drug in it and how does it know right a
fentanyl test strip could only tell you
that there is a a detectable quantity of
fentanyl in whatever substance you're
you're exposing that's stripped to right
it wouldn't tell you whether or not
there is a lethal dose or uh or less
than lethal dose involved so
um it it's it's not it's not the perfect
answer or solution uh simply because
most of the samples from what I
understand from talking to the folks at
DEA and State Police for the last couple
of years unfortunately most of the
samples that are obtained through
investigations or C's contain Fentanyl
all right so virtually most most of the
substances out there contain a
detectable amount of fentanyl xylazine
is more troubling as you may know it's
um it's a sedative that's used by large
animal vets typically
it's in schedule three of the Controlled
Substances Act and it is not an opioid
so therefore an opioid Agonist like
naloxone has no effect on xylazine right
and I'm not aware and I don't think that
there is any uh
manufactured or available testing
material that would allow someone in the
field to test for xylazine right so and
the other question that we're struggling
to get an answer to frankly is what is
the source of the xylazine that is now
showing up in a fairly sizable number of
seizures in New Hampshire is it being
illicitly produced in clandestine Labs
like fentanyl is it being diverted from
the legal Market or is it a combination
of the two so we're still struggling to
try to get the answer to that the
assumption is is that the xylazine that
we're seeing as being clandestinely
manufactured
follow-up
so you've answered the question
reference to test strips
I was also interested in the the type of
testing you described that a police
officer would do with a small substance
in a particular reagent and it would
indicate that there were illegal drugs
is that the same same type of answer
it's the presumptive amount right so if
there is a a sign if there is a
sufficient quantity of drugs to be able
to expose it to a reagent and you need a
bit right and put it in a plastic bag
and mix it with the reagent that gives
you the presumptive indication
presumptively right
that that tested testable substance
contains whatever you're testing it
against right whether it's
methamphetamine heroin or whatever the
other case may be
representative Stone
thank you Mr chairman thank you chief
for taking my question based on your
training experience have you ever found
any drug dealers that are really
concerned with the end users of their
product
unfortunately there are
um you know at the lower level of the
drug trafficking Spectrum a number of
people support their drug use uh by
selling uh smaller quantities of drugs
so the answer to that is yes
um
typically traffickers at the higher
level of the spectrum don't simply
because they know that if they become
their own best customer they're likely
not to survive or make the best business
judgments with respect to drug
trafficking so Folks at the higher end
of the trafficking Spectrum typically
don't use but at middle and low ends of
the traffic I found that a fairly
sizable number of people support their
habits and substance use disorder by
selling it to friends and acquaintances
or
on the street thank you chief
representative Newell
um so I just wanted to clarify first of
all that 10 milligrams is about the size
of a half a grain of rice right it's
it's a very very very small amount to
carry around small bags of 10 milligrams
in each one is
just an interesting thought but the
question that I wanted to ask was
um you know the benefit of you know as
we've said functional test strips just
tell you whether or not there's it's
it's in it it's yes or no
um whereas
um the other analyzing equipment would
be able to give you kind of a breakdown
of what Senate right and uh you know as
one of my colleagues said
um you know there's two sides you can
kind of look at it from either side and
I think I'm curious if you think that
that would be helpful in the overall
um fight against you know
um to to to reduce uh the harm on people
and really to get a handle on these
things for us to know how much of what
there is and then to also be able to get
like an early heads up of what new
things are coming especially with the
prevalence of xylazine now uh very very
difficult thing to handle but don't you
think that knowledge is power that would
be really good for us to to be able to
fight back against it
thank you for your question well it's
it's a philosophical argument all right
and it's a philosophical decision
because what you're what you're
proposing or what you're postulating is
a strategy that bumps up against
facilitating drug use right and and
that's the philosophical question that
we all struggle with right what can we
do to control and reduce because if the
premise is right if the premise is that
we don't want people using illicit drugs
that causes harm to them in the
community right then we don't want to
engage in any sort of
legal exercise that ends up facilitating
drug use which we don't want people to
do from the foundational perspective
right so that's the struggle that we
have and so in a society that we have
today where we're we're effectively
swimming in a sea of illicit drugs right
have in fact do we engage in that kind
of activity without effectively
legalizing possession of controlled
drugs so that's that's really the
problem right can I follow up really
quickly I think
because you brought up kind of what is
the premise right what do we really want
to accomplish I would just put that a
little bit differently I would say the
premise is that we don't want people to
die
and I think that you know something like
this is that's really at at the heart of
harm reduction is you know to say that
you know people may fall down that that
go down that road and it's unfortunate
we don't want to encourage it or
facilitate it but at the end of the day
we want to keep people alive long enough
for them to be able to to you know have
the chance to get out of that if they
can so thank you
you're welcome represent Bolden
thank you
um I think it was like
2015 that the house passed and the
governor signed legislation
um to give immunity from arrest
um if the evidence for possession of
uh a controlled substance was found
um when an orbital overdose was reported
um I think it's called the 9-1-1
immunity law
um and so I know that's like a
complicated way of describing it but
you know if you have drugs on you
um and you're pulled over then you're
charged with possession but if you have
drugs on you and the only reason that
that's come to the awareness of an
officer is because you're at the scene
of an overdose that you reported
then under the law New Hampshire you're
immune from prosecution so my question
was
um in uh in the time period since 2015
have you seen examples of
um drug dealers may be deliberately
causing overdoses so that they could
obtain that immunity because I remember
that that was an argument against the
legislation at the time and sort of was
something that people were worried about
that people would find a way to um
take advantage of the laws it was
proposed so I wasn't sure if maybe you
knew of any instances in which
um drug dealers were causing overdoses
and calling them in to get immunity
drug dealers I don't of course I I can't
hope to speculate what goes through the
mind of a drug dealer and I hope I never
could or will but I don't believe that
in any right world that they would
induce or think about causing a drug
overdose simply to escape prosecution by
way of the 9-1-1 immunity provision
which by the way ladies and gentlemen
has not worked out well has it right
when we're looking at the highest number
of drug overdoses since we began taking
stats in 2015 so the fact that we're
immunizing people because they call
9-1-1 really isn't working out well
I'm not saying that we should reverse
that but I think we should take a look
at what we have done and what is working
and what is not working
um that no actually I think we've gone
far enough a field away from the test
strips do you want to ask a question
about test trips
no okay uh thank you cheers hoping for
the data that he cited um because I get
I think we all get emails with the
overdose statistics and I was hoping
maybe you could share whatever you have
if you have it yeah
she's asking if you have the data as far
oh
I I do have those uh I can tell you that
um last year of course all the
toxicology reports have not been uh
completed for 2022 but uh if all those
toxicology reports come back positive
for controlled drugs uh the number is
sure the office of the medical examiner
has those as well so I can certainly get
those too thank you very much
representative Reed
thank you Mr chairman
um so I'm bringing this back to the test
strips and the way I'm I'm I think we've
you know really veered off so this bill
is about legal you know making
um drug checking equipment
um okay so if a user is going to go and
buy drugs the way I see it is
um this could save a life so they go
they buy their drug they take it
wherever they're going to use they test
it they use the drug I the this back and
forth over 10 milligram amounts and
packaging it and going it I don't think
any drug user is going to package their
drug go get it tested
go back go you that's just not real life
I think we need to bring this back to
legalizing fentanyl test strips to save
lives and if you have an amount of
illegal substance in your car then you
treat it like it is an illegal substance
but if you're pulled over and you have
fentanyl test strips or whatever drug
checking equipment that's fine you know
but to make it okay to drive around
Manchester with little baggies of drugs
saying you're getting tests it doesn't
make sense to me is there a question
representary am I right I guess
[Laughter]
you know does that make sense yeah it
does make sense I'll go back to my
initial statement which is we're not
opposed to fentanyl test drive right
we're not opposed to the notion of it
right and and I think that your analysis
is spot on that folks are not going to
be getting in the car and go well let me
drive down to the local test strip
location and and test this out no
they're not going to do that you're
going to do it at home uh or wherever
they are so
um I think that the best way to get this
through and make it workable is to
remove the provision that contains any
kind of uh controlled substance quantity
and simply legalize test strips for the
purpose that you intended to be used for
thank you very much
representative Murray
Mr chair
the the fact is that there are or will
be drug testing facilities though so
would it be amenable to maybe add in a
clarification that while in the process
of being tested add a drug testing
facility that that amount is like that
amount is legal because I think
otherwise you kind of set up a situation
where there could just be like you know
people go to get their drugs tested and
then police just come and arrest
everybody
right I I I don't know I mean if there's
any sort of speculation that you're
going to establish drug testing
facilities
um I think that we we would all have to
look very carefully at how that would
actually play out in the field right
um and what quantities are we talking
about and there's just a whole range of
issues
um I I think that the start would be to
Simply legalize the testing uh to test
strips that that you're trying to
legalize and and make that something
that people can have and use and and
then if you want to address this testing
facility issue then come back at it
later on and take a look at something
that's uh that's it's workable
okay thank you Chief we appreciate your
time I'm gonna ask now someone who has
something to do with the testing
facilities if you'd like to
is it on
um sorry thank you for
um
um I'm I'm Dr Carrie Nolte I'm a family
nurse practitioner and a nursing
professor and harm reduction researcher
at the University of New Hampshire I'm
Lauren McGinley I'm the executive
director of the New Hampshire harm
reduction coalition
so the first thing that I thought that
representative bolden's bag would be
helpful to illustrate is that there are
two different you know measures when we
think about milligrams as far as potency
so you can have a large pill that is a
10 milligram pill it could be like a
horse pill but you could also have a 10
milligram pill that's super tiny and so
that is not what we're talking about the
what we're talking about is a
weight-based measure and so in a baggie
we're really talking about like this
little corner is 10 milligrams and to
just respectfully correct something that
Chief profansky said my apologies the um
he had cited that the head of Link
Lincoln's head was two micrograms but
the DEA actually uses that same 410
milligrams so I just want to translate
that we're not talking about the potency
we're talking about a weight-based
measure so 10 milligrams does represent
Lincoln's head
um on a Penny thank you I couldn't
remember the coin
um and so I I think I hope that that's
helpful I I think when I'm so happy to
hear that the committee is sound
supportive of the test strips
um which is which is great
um I in reality that's not a positive
change for our state right now fentanyl
test strips are already distributed
through harm reduction programs they're
covered under the syringe service
program so any member of a certain
service program can possess them within
Public Health we always think about a
Swiss Cheese model of we're never going
to do all the things there's no one
solution so we've brought in Good
Samaritan laws we've brought in naloxone
we've brought in harm reduction
programming fentanyl test strips is
another one but comprehensive drug
checking is another one and so I clearly
the discussion that you're having is
whether to bring in comprehensive drug
checking today and So within that you
know we we know now since since we have
heard um talked to you previously
there's already a new synthetic opioid
out
nitazine apologies for the pronunciation
I've only read it and not actually
spoken it
um but we know that that is um
circulating in the drug Supply in the
minute Mid-Atlantic States and Maryland
in particular and the only way we know
that is because they have comprehensive
drug checking in those places and so
what we what we want to be able to do is
that to be on the Forefront of these
things and so as we think about the drug
doths being as high as they are and
having increase last year being the
highest year it's not about a policy
that didn't work it's that our policies
are working it's that we we may have
seen 1500 deaths last year if not for
all these slices of cheese that we've
put in place over the last five years
and So within that time as far as I'm
aware and looking at the medical
examiner reports there hasn't been a
heroin death in the state of New
Hampshire in five years they are all
fentanyl deaths and so when we think
about talking about fentanyl it's
ubiquitous it is the drug Supply it's
not just something that's there and so
you know recently there's been anecdotal
reports that are unverified but of of
people using
um fentanyl test straps on Adderall at a
private school in those testing positive
and so when we talk about all of these
we have to make sure that we can do that
and offer those Services these the
comprehensive drug checking is a proven
strategy
in Massachusetts
um California Rhode Island where they
have seen reductions in deaths and part
of that is not just the testing itself
but the messaging so what we would be
able to message out to people who engage
with treatment programs and harm
reduction programs there's car fentanyl
circulating in the supply use extra
caution
um in in those messaging so it only
takes one task to identify a new
substance instead of a year of of
waiting to find out what it is
um I would just like to point out one
other thing that came up that was a
minor modification So based on the prior
discussion
um we had talked to some other drug
checking experts across the country
um to support representative Muses
Amendment here and under X under 3 XD
um drug packaging means the materials
are items used by persons ingesting
drugs so specifically there we took out
selling or buying to clarify that that
was not the intention that to support
um drug traffickers testing supplies
within that you know within those
conversations where the nominal amount
came from and where that was added was
the concern over compete what you're
talking about today can people
um
can people say I'm bringing this for
drug checking and not be you know I'm
going to tell you for sure that having
their drug dealers are not going to
package this little corner of drugs into
little plastic baggies based on this
it's just not feasible it's not going to
happen in my work with people who use
drugs
um and so where nominal amount came from
was actually legislation in other states
so
um if the if the committee would like to
move to residual I see no problem with
that I think we see no problem with that
but what had happened in other states
was that people were concerned about the
definition of residual and so nominal is
actually meant to imply that residual
amount that little tiny piece now the
other changes in here including moving
all of the terminology so the original
Bill asked to eliminate preparing
packaging repackaging blah blah
um completely and loud and clear that
was heard that wasn't feasible that may
interfere with probable cause but here
we're we are specifying that this is for
you know drug checking so the mechanism
of it would be that
um as the chief had spoken about I think
it's what he was describing as the same
units that we're looking to use that
police have used for a public health use
um and so within that you know we need
to you can do a test that says this has
xylazine fentanyl methamphetamine Etc on
the spot you can tell people what is in
there you can say yes this Adderall has
fentanyl in it
but you need to send it out in order to
quantify it and so that's why in order
to be protected in order to do this work
we need to have preparing packaging
repackaging all of that not because we
we want to eliminate packaging from a
probable cause but because we as public
health
practitioners need to be able to do that
for this program to be effective
sorry thank you for all your time all
the different no actually that you um
raised a couple questions so
if the if the bill said
packaging materials for use by the
testing facility versus just leaving it
blank would that not
narrow it down so that only you would be
that would be
a nominal amount definition is under
drug checking already so
um that to me
clarifies the purpose I mean the only I
guess the only other thing and I say
this as a researcher would be that you
know I have a goal of doing research on
wounds and Drug checking and so you know
I might not be a testing facility but
you know it's part of that research and
where we can see and and quantify what
xylazine is doing to people's skin and
that's my next question
um the chief brought up you know
the existence of these drug checking
facilities are you proposing opening one
or how would what's the mechanics of
this sure yeah I think that
um we would love to I mean I think part
of it is we need the legislation in
place to seek grants and support
um they are covered
um you know they there has been Federal
funding allocated to this we're not
looking for State funding at all
um and especially for piloting it and
getting it out there research funding
um is a possibility
um I think that
um what we have seen and I I totally
understand the idea that like no one's
going to go to these things but in every
other place they are they they exist
they do and they're overburdened by
people wanting tests and samples and
it's it that's a really important thing
because that is something that a person
who uses drugs is doing to protect their
own health and safety they're taking
action to go check their drugs
um and and that leads to other Behavior
years of protecting their health and
safety like reducing use getting into
treatment whatever it is
so if someone walks in and they say hey
I've got this could you test it
you have to ship it out is what you're
saying to have it tested or no yeah so
in the the ftir machines are a small
handheld tiny thing those are what can
be used at the point of care and those
can so that's where you could say yes
this has methamphetamine and Fentanyl in
it but in order to quantify is it you
know one part Fentanyl and 50 Parts
um methamphetamine or whatever it is
that has to be sent out to a lab and so
previously when I had provided a
testimony to the committee I had sent
information about drugs data in those
reports and that's that lab that's that
centralized database that to be honest
we don't contribute to in New Hampshire
but we benefit from from the samples
that are being sent in from Maine and
Massachusetts and Rhode Island
where is this testing facility I believe
physically they're located in California
so doesn't that also raise federal law
questions with you shipping drugs across
the country I'm not sure on the
particulars about that but I know that
those have been addressed through oh
okay so I did get to go visit one of the
harm reduction based drug testing
facilities in Lawrence Massachusetts it
was incredibly eye-opening wonderful to
see the program I did ask that question
and it falls under some protections
offered because the shipment is going to
a research-based university
um and so this is it's part of a
research program
okay any questions from the committee
representative Newman
yeah could you just give a little
thumbnail sketch of what these
facilities are like it sounds like your
facility is different from a drug
checking facility
and that drug checking facility has to
send it to a lab could you just kind of
clear up the difference between all of
that and how successful this is in the
other states why do people just go there
to get it and come sure yeah I would be
happy to so like I said in Lawrence
Massachusetts
um their drug checking facility sits
within a syringe service program or harm
reduction program that is sponsored by
their Community Health Center and give
some space there people would walk in
they would be able to engage in syringe
Disposal Services first so being able to
dispose of their syringes within a bio
Hazard bin they would then come through
they would meet with a care coordinator
who would ask them if they would like to
have HIV testing hepatitis C testing if
they needed help with any wounds and if
they had any drugs to test today at that
point the person would come in place the
drugs down the chemist would go through
the process of checking each individual
sample to just give an example of how
small the samples needed to be people
don't even need to bring in substances
they could bring in equipment that they
use to mix drugs like a cooker or a
cotton a very very very small residual
amount left over on something and even
that was able to be tested then Cole
would be able to deliver preliminary
results about that all the while I would
say it takes about
seven minutes per test
um and then in that amount of time
people are able to either get their hep
C or HIV testing done talk to somebody
about if they need a safe place to sleep
a warm meal that day do you need an
extra sleeping bag here's your Sharps
container and here are your initial
results and then in about a week to two
weeks people as they come in and out of
that Center are able to also receive
their confirmatory results which is what
amusement
I just wanted you to to try to maybe
expand on on a thought that you
introduced earlier you had said that in
in the middle Mid-Atlantic states where
they actually have drug checking uh in
process now one of the things that
they're actually able to do is to to
identify and track new drugs that come
into the system and things like clusters
and you said that currently because we
don't do this in New Hampshire we don't
have that that kind of data and I
how much of a handicap is it not to have
data like that uh in in this state if
you're actually really trying to stop
fentanyl deaths
yeah I mean I'll speak to that
um it it
it's frustrating as a public health
professional I wish that the people that
live 30 minutes away from me who are in
Massachusetts I wish that I had their
range of sight their Polaroid picture of
their drug Supply situation is much
clearer than ours is right now so we
don't know which way they're traveling
we don't know what's what substances we
should be focusing a lot of our effort
on talking to our participants about yes
there are people that utilize fentanyl
but there are also people who
occasionally on the weekend utilize
cocaine and so if I had an idea of what
our cocaine Supply realistically looked
like I knew that those recreational
users of cocaine could be an area of
focus for us instead of focusing on some
other areas where maybe the data isn't
going to point us in that direction
immediately
and I will just add that there's also a
a clinical benefit to this so we know
that there's thousands of
hospitalizations in New Hampshire for
injecting related infections and wounds
and so as a nurse practitioner in in
healthcare for the homeless and doing
Outreach you know we've seen these these
changing wounds these sores these things
we think that they're related to
xylazine
um because that's what we've heard from
surrounding states
um but we don't know that and it would
actually change your treatment decision
if this was substance use related or
maybe a bacteria a different bacterial
infection so so there's a benefit to
reducing hospitalizations and better
treating infection as well
how how far away are you from being able
to let's say this became law tomorrow
how long would it take you to to get one
of these facilities up and running
one that's a great question I'd love to
know the answer
um myself
um but uh one thing that I I had meant
to ask
um the uh committee was that for
whatever reason this the original Bill
the effective date was January 1st of
next year
um in many bills come through as
effective in July first and so if that
is a possible Amendment you would
consider
um I think we could get there sooner
um but if we see this if this does come
through for um July 1st we would be
searching for funding
um you know within the months preceding
that in preparation so my hope would be
you know early within the year if that
were the case
who was actually we as UNH involved in
this or is it just a coalition who is
this yeah so it'd be New Hampshire harm
reduction Coalition
um and we have service regions for
direct service and Stratford County
Manchester and Concord and then we
support the other syringe service
programs or harm reduction programs that
exist throughout the state
so UNH isn't involved he just happened
to work there is that is that correct or
I hope that UNH is involved we'll have
to negotiate that later but you know
there yeah I mean I think as far as um
this is something that it falls within
my harm reduction research program of
research
um and
um preliminary talks we do have some of
this equipment and lab supplies that are
utilized for other purposes or no longer
utilized
um but obviously I can't speak on behalf
of my employer that they're willing to
make that but once the bill is passed we
can hopefully do that
any further questions
I represent Stone
thank you Mr chair I have two quick
questions and thank you for taking the
questions the first one is when someone
comes in from the public what quantity
of test strips do you give out
um
uh whatever they ask for typically we
are encouraging people to take the
fentanyl test strips about how many
um
what's your typical compliment when
somebody so we make a kit we have an
overdose prevention kit those currently
have two fentanyl test strips in it um
but if someone came in and they had
utilized a fentanyl test strip and they
felt like they would work that into the
way they use drugs we would be happy
handing them 20 or 25 or 30. okay thank
you my second question if I'm allowed to
proceed uh you mentioned residual
testing doesn't that kind of
put you in a position where they've
already utilized drugs if you're doing
residue testing after the fact of using
the drugs
um yes you're you are correct so um
sometimes people will come to the drug
testing facilities uh the harm reduction
programs and um say I use this drug it
did not at all feel like what I was
expecting or I
um I had an overdose I experienced an
adverse reaction that I was not prepared
for can you please tell me what's going
um just really quickly um just because
of the
oh I lost my train of thought with the
whole Newman thing okay
um
I think there's something in the air I
don't know no I mean I think I just I I
think I had had it in my mind to ask
this but maybe it's
clear by now but um that
by by explaining that you can seek
grants you're saying that this is
widely accepted I I want to make sure I
understand like it's federally not just
tolerated but encouraged
and that it's it just comes down to
individual states
to allow for this kind of activity yeah
I think that's what I'm trying to wrap
you know I failed every science class I
ever went in and uh
um you said it was a weight-based
measure but then you talked about
Lincoln's head on a penny which doesn't
seem like a weight thing so but maybe it
doesn't matter anymore because you're
also saying that residual is fine with
you and
like I was looking at the syringe law
the syringe exchange law from what was
that like 2017 or something and um it
just talks about residual in there
because like obviously you can't
exchange a used syringe without also
moving drugs like you can't transport it
to another location because without
moving drugs because there's always
going to be something in there
um so I don't know there's just a couple
of things that were on my mind while you
were talking was
I believe we already have a variety of
laws that allow the transport of a
minimal amount of drugs
for various you know for the purpose of
various good outcomes ideally and then
um acknowledging that the feds are
pretty cool with this given that they're
handing out money for it and that is
just our job to enable you to do that
and then um the difference between
weight and Lincoln's head yes anything
you want to say that but you know I
think the community's kind of all set to
you think the the Lincoln's head on a
penny is slightly difficult we utilize
that as just a very quick tool that
somebody could utilize if they were
using a fentanyl test strip at home if
the mass of any substance out there were
significantly higher than what we're
seeing substances appear as then you're
right it would be different but it's
kind of just that these are generally
going to be a powder that are around the
same weight and that weight is going to
fit about into Lincoln's head on a penny
additionally I I tell this to everybody
Amazon sells 10 milligram Scoops if
anybody feels like looking them up you
are able to gauge very easily how much a
powdered scoop would scoop if it was 10
milligrams
um I just want to speak to the the feds
on both bills for fentanyl test strips
and all types of test strips
benzodiazepine and xylazine
um the the so samsa and the CDC in April
of 2021 actually made a widespread
widespread request to all of their
funded agencies to say please start
utilizing fentanyl test strips as an
overdose prevention tool so that was
April of 21.
um
and while ssps are covered in being able
to dispense those I don't see enough
people each month to make a dent in what
would be able to be done if we had a
recovery Community organizations doctors
offices Med Vans homeless Outreach
workers homeless shelters being able to
distribute fentanyl test strips as well
and then Federal funding
are the feds okay with drugs oh okay
um yeah and so I I think there's many
um both Public Health projects research
projects that are funded federally
um it's very interesting when you
comment on like it's up to
um states to make their own decision
um part of part of what we've seen in
other states is when you look at these
the the drug paraphernalia law that this
is
um amending
um it these terms are in almost every
state or were at one point in every
state that cultivating growing
harvesting bill so there's sort of like
a template of drug paraphernalia that
was enacted in across the states
um with a lot of variation and so not
anticipating that then drug checking
would become this really important
overdose prevention tool and so you know
then it is up to each state individually
to decide to amend them in order to
enable it
um and the one other thing I wanted to
say the the residual piece
um you know it that would be fine
um I think that would be I I don't see
an issue for that for nominal going away
what I'm the only reason it was in there
was that residual was in other states
got pushed back and they wanted a
measurement that was quantifiable and
that was that was what we came to for
what was needed for testing
thank you okay I think the committee has
enough information at this point um
we're going to go ahead and close this
work session and we'll take it up at um
executive in a little while we need to
move on to the next public hearing so
thank you very much for helping us again
and I'm going to close the work session
on 287 470 and open the public hearing
on HP 397 and invite the sponsor to
good morning sorry for making you wait
so long
it's all right work happens
um I apologize I put my kids out the
call so um hopefully that wasn't
disruptive my name is Emily Phillips I'm
uh Rockingham district 7 representative
this has already been passed through
Health and Human Services on consent but
what it does is it decriminalizes minor
children who handle hypodermic needles
or pen tips for say their parents who
have an authorized prescription for it
I'm a type 1 diabetic so I actually
didn't know this was uh
you know illegal but my my daughter will
deliver my pen needle to me or my hold
my purse with my insulin in it or my
syringes
um so the act of her handling that
currently is against the law so this
will allow minor children to become what
we are what we're determining to be
called authorized agents and as long as
they are doing so under supervision of
somebody with a legit prescription need
they would be authorized to handle those
devices it's been trimmed down from the
original version so um
the pretty simple Bill I just think it's
um a law that shouldn't even exist so
we're fixing it
thank you anyone have any questions
representative Stone
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question has there been any
any history of any uh juveniles
convicted or charged with a crime of
handling a hypodermic needle so if they
had been it would be sealed so we
wouldn't know there'd be no tracking
information there correct and it's on
their chins correct
there wouldn't be any tracking under
your chins
I don't know the answer to that so um
you know we don't want to
leave so I think the law as it exists
now there's a flaw there and you
wouldn't want it to be used against
somebody under you know um
child family services as a neglectful
action
as it's written now I think that
corrects it
how did this uh come about for a change
in legislation it was um I guess last
year was submitted and it was there was
more to it there was something about
um the needle exchange program allowing
miners to have access through that
program as well and some other
information I think it was trying to
repeal the entire law and this just adds
the authorized agent aspect
um so it was presented to me so I'm a
type 1 diabetic I carry all my supplies
and some none of the representatives
says you know that you're breaking the
law right like if my daughter holds that
and I said no I didn't explain this to
me so I was like well I'll I'll sponsor
this so that's how I came into my hands
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking this question
I spent the last two years working at a
summer camp
and in that summer camp the the campers
are required
to be buddies
so there was always a protection that
would be two of them
and there were some cases where a person
had a nut allergy
and his buddy carried his EpiPen what
you're telling me is that under state
law now as it stands right now that was
actually an unlawful Act
thank you um another example I didn't
and I'm sorry I didn't prepare a written
statement but a teenage babysitter who
had to help administer insulin to a
child although the teenage babysitter
was given a permission by the parents to
help that child that teenage babysitter
is breaking the law uh same thing with
an EpiPen although the EpiPen thing it's
life-saving so you could be covered
under the Good Samaritan law or
something in that example but there's
something called glucagon which is a um
a life-saving
vial that would be so if I went
unconscious I had a low blood sugar I
this product is advised to be injected
into my thigh when I'm unconscious so
I've taught my children who I feel
responsible enough to save my life
because minutes matter how to use this
so if they did save my life they would
be covered by Good Samaritan but why I
teach them to on how to do it when I'm
unconscious while I'm teaching them it's
representative yokella thank you thank
you
thank you and thank you uh uh committee
for
uh hearing my testimony today
um I will be able to bring a little bit
more uh history to this because
this was my bill from uh two years ago
and
um I
found the bill because I was looking in
the pharmacy statute for something else
um
and I stumbled across this legislation
or this part of this the law and didn't
understand one why it was in the
pharmacy statute that the kids were
prohibited from doing stuff because the
penalties are the same as a penalty for
a pharmacist so that didn't really make
a whole lot of sense
and so my first
um attempt with this law was just to
repeal it because in reality the I think
that
um we're kind of moving away from these
penalties about syringes and stuff like
that and just um because uh we saw that
when we uh outlawed syringes
um the there was an increase of reuse of
syringes and stuff like that and that
caused other harms and so Most states
are moving away from
um
forbidding the actual paraphernalia and
just concentrating on the drug itself
and so I try to repeal it at first
but that um was uh too extreme for for
Health and Human Services so
um the bill bill died however in the in
the law under uh Pharmacy there's
already a definition of
um authorized agent
so during during this last year I I
propose that we just uh
add the language of saying hey uh you
know there's these children like the
example of the the partner or the friend
if you're you know you show your friend
if they hold it if you
if you let your um you know friend hold
this these uh the needle or these Auto
injectors and stuff like that it was
it's currently a crime um it's not
always prosecuted however two
representative Stone's question there is
data
um we're not sure about
um the technicalities of the specific
instances but we do have data on how
often these are charged
at least I did get that data as of 2021
when I first put the bill in and I have
that uh it was much more charged back in
1998 and 1999 there was up to
um 117
um cases filed against children
um but in the more recent years like
2015 there was two and then there was
nothing until 2018 there was one more
and then 2021 there was one more so it
was it's been trailing off of
um a lot and so we don't those cases are
obviously sealed because they involve
minor so we don't know like what the
um
the circumstances of the case were but
um I felt that this uh that this uh
authorized agent language and making it
clear that
um it has to be for nefarious purposes
of the the handling of the of the uh
hypodermic needles I thought
um would protect from
um a zealous prosecution
um and so that's why I
um
I put this this bill in and supported
the bill and I'm happy to
answer any questions thank you um do you
have any uh what was very concerning to
me and I hadn't thought of this was the
the reference the representative made
about um not necessarily criminal
charges but you being used by um
um youth services or whoever to
potentially take children out of a home
just because of this because it's
illegal do you have any doubt on that or
have you heard anything like that
um thank you uh for the question
so
there there have been a few people so
that this bill is has two sections one
of them is the child is actually
committing a crime when you give the the
child or the Buddy
um the access to this needle when they
have possession of it
um but also the person that gave the
person uh the needle also is cremating a
crime so there's two sections of this
law that we are changing and under that
law I also have the stats but only since
um
and there was
two in 2013 two in 2014 two or four in
2014 to in 2015 and then it skips all
the way down to 2018 was one
um in circuit court and then Superior
Court there was there's like uh one in
2013 2016 and then two in 2021. so it
it's not very often that has been used
against adults
um I don't know the exact nature of
those cases and and what happened with
those those adults if those were dealers
or whatever then it it may not have been
affected but it's entirely possible that
it could be used in in you know against
a parent thank you
I'm sorry can you see your name
representative Howard thank you
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you uh
representative yukela for taking my
question uh so for me I'm just curious
about what if there is a minor driving a
vehicle and per se uh there is
um a uh a kit for insulin uh use in in
the back seat uh could there be a
possibility that because they are not
being uh directed uh that they could be
charged still
thank you for the question
um this is not that was not my language
this is the health and human services
they had some they had some people in it
that were uh that were
concerned that
um an authorized agent wasn't
too broad for and so they added some
language to try and make it more narrow
I obviously don't didn't I think that
authorized agent is clear enough
but yes if if you know Emily left her
her needle in the car and and let her
kid use the car but didn't remove the
needle
um okay or a neighbor's kid use the car
technically they're in possession of it
and and is it under direct supervision
you know all of that stuff it seems like
they made it unnecessarily restrictive
in health and human services and kind of
that's why we're we're in criminal
justice right so you can say like uh
that that doesn't really make a whole
lot of sense
um
um but my intention is just that you
know if the kid is not using it or not
using it for a nefarious purpose if
there if someone had Elite uh has it
um inappropriate purpose then they're
not going to be getting charged that's
the main goal and thrust of this and to
be honest since there already is you
know examples of people just being
currently committing the crime
um I'd rather have something get passed
than than
um than uh then just keep continuing
down this road of people being cremating
crimes and then selective prosecution
yeah thank you thank you representative
Murray
thank you Mr chair
um I actually didn't realize that we
were the second committee on this until
you mentioned Health Human Services for
so thank you for doing that because I
was looking at the introduced version of
the bill
um so with what you're saying you know
I'm looking at the under direct
supervision part with representative
Phillips example of like her kids having
to revive her with a pen would then they
not that this bill not cover them
because they're not being supervised
because she's unconscious
thank you for the question I think that
in the emergency situation there's there
is an exception like a Good Samaritan
exception kind of stuff and so you you
could technically be charged but then
have a defense that say oh I was being a
Good Samaritan you know I was saving
their life they were you know under and
so you could have an exception but
technically yes you would be still under
breaking this technical law and so I
think you know that's why we're in
criminal justice to to make sure the law
is correct okay thank you and then I
just wanted to clarify
you want us to pass this as amended or
you would have preferred for us to
revert it back to the original language
thank you for the question I my My
ultimate goal is to
just clean up the language so that I
think that people that there's no
possibility of of
a child being put in the system
unnecessarily and for unappropriate
means
um and since the law is so broad right
now I'm happy with something but
obviously I think that the bill I I
submitted was good and so but uh I uh
I'm not entirely opposed to you know I I
didn't pull it off of consent and fight
it off on the floor if it it got past in
consent I was happy to
move forward with it so I would prefer
the other one but I'm okay with leaving
it as
or any fixes that you need to pass
yeah I have a question of the chair oh
go ahead and it has to do with our
responsibilities here
as the second committee and as I
understand it this is a bill that went
through and it was amended by Health and
Human Services so so this is the bill
that this amendment doesn't have to be
approved that's what we'll see when we
get to a session is that correct
well it was amended in health and human
services so that's now the bill right so
we don't have to so we don't have to do
it now we could have mend it if we
wanted to we could amend it if we wanted
to I understand that
so it comes to us as a second committee
and my understanding has been that it
comes to us because we are the committee
that is
involved with the appropriateness of
penalties or some other issue that has
to do with criminal justice or Public
Safety
so
we can amend the the policy part of this
if we wanted to but for right and I I'm
looking at this and I don't see any
penalties or anything that we are
looking at other than we're talking
mostly about policy and trying to
understand what what the policy is so
I think you've cleared I think I've
clarified it enough to myself as I
talked good talk thank you
I I do want to let you remind you that
there are penalties there it's the same
penalties as a as a um as a pharmacist
and so it is a misdemeanor I believe for
uh a person and then a business it's a
like a felony
so
this is just a the portion of the
statute that's being amended the
existing penalty portion remains
um question oh representative Murphy I'm
sorry
oh thank you Mr chair
um thank you for taking my question
um in regards to the the child
protection concerns
I'm I'm I'm hearing like the diabetic
issue and I certainly understand that
but having worked in child protection
you know that sometimes these things
aren't quite as obvious
um and I wonder about those cases that
were actually prosecuted and wonder if
it was because there was a child was in
possession of a syringe full of an
injectable illegal drug
um not a you know not a not something
that's prescribed for diabetics but
um having worked and seen enough of
those cases I can certainly see why
there are concerns about possession of
um of um syringes and with a needle I'm
assuming not just the syringe we're
talking a needle attachment or that's
the the question I have that it sounds a
little bit overly broad to me and I just
wondering what the reality is of
how many cases are actually prosecuted
who who's gonna who's gonna the person
that'll be prosecuted would I would
imagine would be the the parent a
guardian right of whoever the the child
they're Prosecuting six-year-olds they
can yes so thank you for the question
um so uh I think
we were just giving some examples of
possible
um things most of the I'm not aware of
any
um Health and Human Service involvement
in any of these cases these would be
police charges not necessarily going
through health and humans or you know
like uh
um you know neglect case necessarily
um but yes they could charge the
six-year-old they could charge a 17 year
old they could charge and they do and
they have
um that's so those were the numbers that
I gave at the beginning whereas back in
1997 is the first records that I have it
was
um once 78 cases in circuit court and 14
in Superior Court and so I could give
you the list and forward this
information that I had on the cases for
um
for
these that I got from Richard head which
is the the um person for kind of liaison
for the judicial system I got this
information from him and so I could
forward it on to you and the in the
committee if if that's helpful I mean I
think you're going to exec it in a few
minutes so I'm not sure how much time
you would have time to review it but
there are charges um that can be and
have been brought but it's it it
definitely starts trailing off
um to like below 10 cases in 2004 and
then it starts trailing way off to like
um
um so there was over a hundred and 2018
and or or uh sorry in 1998 and 1999
there were over a hundred cases against
minors
and then
all the way to 20 2004 then it starts
dropping off to like under 10 cases
per year per for Miners And so it's not
being used readily and uh anymore and a
lot of some of the officers that came to
the hearing last year were surprised I
was even uh uh law they just weren't
really aware of it because who would
think to look in in the pharmacy statute
for you know charging someone
so thank you thank you
a six-year-old or whatever yeah
representative tenzar and then you got a
question right yeah thank you chairman
thank you representative those cases
that you're referencing are those New
Hampshire cases
oh yeah absolutely all of these are New
Hampshire cases there so Richard head is
the the liaison for the judicial system
in New Hampshire and so all of these are
based on what I ask them to do is look
up how many cases were uh charged under
this statute that I was trying to repeal
and so these are all the all the cases
I'm not sure how many of them would be
have been covered by this authorized
agent exception thank you thank you
representative Newell
so just to clarify with the you know if
there were charges that there were an
illegal substance in it that would be a
separate charge right it would be a
separate charge for the substance and
you know possession of the substance and
then also and then a separate one from
having the actual syringe
thank you thank you for the um the
question and that was the sentiment that
I kind of got from Richard head that it
was often charged in multiple multiple
charges this was very rarely charged in
so it's an additional charge that they
could plead down to
that looks like that's it all right
thank you thank you anyone else
anyone else wishing to testify on this
bill that has not testified
seeing none I'm going to close the
and at this point we're going to take a
30 minute break and then we'll come back
um
tomorrow
hey
um
yeah
what about you representative did you
pick up any of this I listened to this
last one that bill should have never
gone to HHS the beginning
so because it's Bad Manners to change
your policy but they shouldn't have had
the policy to begin with it should have
it's not a big deal
really like trying to hold and learn
I just kind of set a bar at the
beginning
yeah yeah
if you need to you know run them to get
um
foreign
hello
hi
well good I'm I've been conquered right
no I'm finished at nine I teach from 7
30 to 9.
expect so short
uh we're TR we're trying to make it a
little earlier because Don is now using
her scooter or power chairs so we'd like
to we try to move it up like you know
okay all right I'll see you then
uh four o'clock for the hewards
okay well that's what I told him just a
minute ago also I just I talked to Beth
sergeant and uh she's you know just
became aware of this and is you know no
one you know is talking about killing it
in the Senate Judiciary so
because
oh yeah she left the meeting here so she
oh it's oh that's right it's study
committee okay all right uh Republic
killer but anyway uh she uh Beth
sounded like she'd like you to testify
oh well okay all right okay all right
I'll keep the chair charged
oh but by the way I don't know I have no
idea uh by the way the stakeholders were
telling
yeah because Beth was there for me that
you don't nobody the only person that
the subcommittee I mean
okay I don't well I don't know that they
have to maybe post it in the hallway
kind of thing
I don't know where it's supposed to be
well okay uh well you can you could
certainly
well I don't know is it worth something
is it worth mentioning but okay
I no no he just wanted to go to the
I've done even less work than usual
which is that's it's a pretty low bar as
it is so
anyway I just want to pass that on all
right
it's like five bills to exactly we
haven't exact anything yet
at this point I'm opening the executive
session on House Bill 287
and I'm going to recognize
representative Reed for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I moved to OTP
is there a second
representative proof seconds
and would you like to speak to your
motion representative yes I think um
House Bill 287 is a good harm reduction
tool and I can only see positives with
this Bill thank you representative would
you like to speak to you second uh I
feel the same way and uh not much else
to add
I am I'm going to say I I agree I think
that this um the clean first step for
this is just the test strips
however I do see some value in houseboat
470 and I'd like to see where where the
where they're going with that um there
was discussion of a
of some kind of testing center and I
think that those are interesting ideas
but I'd like to see a little more
definition in a little more Plan before
we legislate and I'd like to legislate
to that versus just throwing it open
and then figuring out what comes of it
um
having said that 287 I strongly support
anyone else would like to speak
representative Rhodes thank you Mr
chairman
I will vote for the Autumn pass motion
for
the test strips I I just feel like I
have to say I do actually have concerns
about it I I am looking at the other
side of the coin and I I almost look at
this as we're telling people that it's
okay to go out and do drugs as long as
you test them first and I I do not agree
with that
if this is going to save somebody's life
then great
um I don't think that this is going to
do anything to stop the drug problem I
don't think that this is going to do
anything to help get the fentanyl off
the streets in any way straight perform
and hopefully I'm proved wrong again I
will vote for it but I I do have
tremendous concerns but
I'll take your guys all word that this
is the right thing to do
thank you I I will say that I share your
concerns but for me it's a matter of uh
as a parent being able to have something
like this at my disposal if I find
something in my child's you know stuff
to test and see what it is uh just for
that alone I think is a good standpoint
further discussion
representative scitec
I just might might mention it's called
an attitude that's coloring all of my
outlooks on the various bills we're
looking at uh Chief last name from
Bedford uh pointed out in his testimony
they're really not winning the war on
drugs so why even bother is it part of
me acts that way so I hear
representative Rhodes fighting I I'm
ready to say Legalize It make a mic
Lifesavers but that's not responsible
but it's uh
it's a sense unfortunately that I have
thank you
further discussion
seeing nonetheless the clerk to call the
roll the motion of the floor is ought to
pass on House Bill 287.
Vice chair Rhodes yes representative
Pratt
yes representative scitec
representative pru yes representative
janvin
representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes
representative tensar yes representative
gathrate
representative Muse yes
representative Bolden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Newman
yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes
representative Howard yes and
representative vote Yes
chairman Roy
CE yes motion is unanimous
House Bill 287 motion about to pass
cares unanimously any objection to
consent
that will go on consent
with that I'll close the executive
session I'll spell 287 open executive
session on House Bill 470 I will
recognize myself to make a motion I'm
going to move retain
do I have a second
by representative gaththright
um I'll speak to my motion
as I said in the previous executive
session I don't think that this bill is
quite ready I I think that we need a
little more information on on how these
um
if these testing centers are going to
set up I'd like to see what they look
like I have some grave concerns about
what happened with some of the needle
exchange programs where it ended up
being places where people would go to do
drugs and I'd like to see some some
actual
information some protection some guard
rails I just think it needs a little
more work and I think legalizing this
ahead of some type of a plan kind of
puts the car before the horse which is
why I'd like to retain it so that we can
maybe do some work on it and come out
with a piece of legislation if necessary
would you like to speak to your second
speaking to the promise Prime sponsor um
and he was okay with the retain I am as
well I think there's a little more work
that we can do with it
thank you further discussion
seeing nonetheless to clerk to call the
roll the motion on floor is to retain
how oh did I miss somebody I'm sorry
represent means go ahead
yeah I just wanted to say I I support uh
the motion to retain the bill because it
is important
um that we get this right
and I think uh having a little bit of
extra time to do that will help help us
not only get the bill right but
hopefully to build uh more consensus
around the fact that we actually need to
do more in New Hampshire uh to save
lives
so what retaining will do essentially is
is put us in a position where we're not
killing the bill we're not forcing a
vote on the floor where people are going
to have to make a black and white
decision what we what we're going to do
is we're we passed 287 that's on its way
so legalizing fentanyl test strips is on
its way to happening and I believe it's
on consent so that's a very positive
thing
and what retaining this bill does is it
puts us in a position to actually build
on that Good Start
later on this year and introduce
legislation or not not introduce
legislation in the next session but
actually to change this legislation
so that we we actually can address
the issues that have been raised in a in
a sensible way and keep making progress
and I think that is what we need to do
in order to make a dent with uh with the
overdose deaths that we're seeing in New
Hampshire so what I have liked to have
seen this bill go through yes because
there there are probably lives at a bill
like this could have saved but it is
important to get it right it is
important to get consensus and it is
really important in this legislature to
get it passed so I think that's what
we're going to work for
thank you and and I wholeheartedly agree
that um if we were to pass it today all
of us still have questions of our own
and our colleagues on the floor would
have questions and I don't think we'd be
able to answer them so I I don't think
it would have a positive uh future if we
were to just cut it loose like it is so
I agree we should do some more work on
it
um anyone else
see none I'll ask the court to call the
roll the motion on the floor is to
retain House built 470. Vice chair
Rhodes
representative Pratt
yes representative scitec
representative Prue yes representative
janfrin yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tanzar yes
representative Catherine
representative news yes representative
Bolden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes
representative Newman yes the clerk
votes yes representative Newell yes
representative Howard yes representative
vote Yes
chairman Roy cheer votes yes motion is
unanimous
so House Bill 470 has been retained and
we'll see
with that I'm going to
yes we do yeah and with that I'm going
to open executive session on House Bill
and I'm going to recognize myself for a
motion again
I'm going to
move on to pass on House Bill 397. do I
I think Peru is first
um yeah well maybe
um and I'll speak to that we had some
discussion
um that this bill probably is not
necessary based on several other bills
that
um make it legal already
with regard to prescriptions
um and we also heard that there's
probably not been anyone prosecuted
recently or for some time just based on
the fact that they had needles and it
was always some other type of substance
involved so it wasn't just a needle
having said that I do think that the
bills at best it's not going to hurt
anyone and that it could possibly help
with regard to cases involving custody
and things of that nature where someone
tries to use that
um so if it's if it's still hanging out
there that there's a potential that it's
illegal for a child to have their
parents EpiPen or their insulin I don't
think it will hurt
to pass the bill
would you like to speak to your second
I I agreed that uh
one I'm not really sure if this is
necessary but if it helps to uh
prevent
an innocent person kind of getting
sucked up into the system uh I'm okay
with that right because
um
I know when I was a kid
um my cousin was a diabetic and I used
to carry his glucagon form as well so I
I get that whole piece that somebody
might be holding a syringe and and
somebody might look at them and say why
do you have that you have no reason to
have it but
this will cover them and take away all
that so
that's it thank you
um and and I agree as well the first
thing I look at on a piece of
legislation is Do no harm in um this
bill I don't see a way where it's going
to do any harm so if it's possible to do
a little good then so be it um further
I just have a question that I don't
think was answered in or even asked in
the uh public hearing
has to do with the last sentence in the
first paragraph that says use of a
hypodermic needle is
hypodermics need a contrary to the
intent of of the prescription is not
permitted under this statute so I don't
know use of by who is that mean or that
does that just mean whether when the
person uh when the tri when the
authorized agent who is a minor
is found with a needle that has
something in it other than what the
intent of the prescription said
what exactly does that mean to what's
going to happen to that child
well um according to all it does as far
as the bill is related is it would take
away the protections of this bill for
that child so whatever would then
normally flow from his possession of
that illegal substance would happen this
bill only covers them if with protection
if they have a syringe with the
prescription substance in it that's
supposed to be in it go ahead
so that means
it they would be subject to depend to
whatever the penalties of the law are
whether they are a trusted agent or not
thank you as far as I can read it the
only protection that this bill gives is
someone who is using it the way it's
supposed to be according to the
prescription
further comments questions
uh
representative Stone
thank you Mr chair I'll uh be voting
against autopass on this bill I don't
think the
testimony today provided uh really
compelling reasons to change anything uh
in the juvenile system as some of us
know if it's possession of say a
resident a residue case involving a
syringe that's really the uh selling
point and there's still no real
disposition at the end of that
I just see this is uh problematic if
you're going to allow miners to have
possession of needles Without Really uh
having again another mechanism to
enforce anything it kind of puts us
thank you anyone else
representative scitec
would somebody refresh my memory what
was I thought representative e ocella
was talking about an amendment that uh
that HHS put in there was what bill was
that about because there was no
Amendment on this no this is the amended
form of the bill they amended it when
they had it in their possession and they
the authorized agent
okay
anyone else our representative um
um
I don't know I I struggle with the bill
as well
um I'm not going to be voting in favor
of the bill
um one of the things that was brought to
our attention was
in the bill it uses RSA 318
however when the question was asked of
the cases
um
there were other charges which led me to
believe that they probably were
teenagers not like children 12 and under
um
I would have liked to
um since
um the prom sponsor received it from
attorney head I would have liked to had
a conversation with him about the
information that was given out today
so for that reason
um I believe that the young people were
charged
because of what might have been in the
um syringe and um
or they might have been users themselves
I don't know I'm just throwing that out
there
so I will not be supporting this thank
you and
it's also possible that they weren't so
I guess we just don't know
um representative Howard thank you Mr
chair I am in support of OTP I believe
that this bill would remove uh the
opportunity for uh minors to actually
become victims and any opportunity to
limit a juvenile going into a uh a
prison system is beneficial because of
course it affects their lives and could
potentially uh ruin that life and lead
them down a path that we would not like
to see them go down
uh thank you
thank you
representative Stone
thank you Mr chair just to clarify for
the committee uh any juvenile who was
found in possession of a needle even
with say heroin or cocaine residue is
not going to go to jail or prison that's
reality under New Hampshire law secondly
uh in 2001 the state of New Hampshire uh
this legislative body ended up
decriminalizing uh possession of a
needle without a prescription and like I
looked it up and it was in 2001 so we
haven't really had
I think significant issues into
involving juvenile population to justify
this Bill thank you
represent Baldwin
I'm just
were made that simply an arrest or
charges can have even if they end up
being dropped later
um and I know that for example in some
schools children minors can face
disciplinary action on the part of
administration just by virtue of having
been charged and that can affect their
ability to attend classes and continue
with their normal curriculum so there's
a lot on the line even if we think that
someone isn't going to end up in the
prison system
representative Murphy
thank you Mr chair I agree with
representative stoned the points that
he's made
um in terms of uh prosecution of
children
um under 12 I'm not aware
um that that that actually happens I
know there were a few cases cited but
none of the details really available
around that so I mean I I think it could
lead us to speculate all kinds of things
but the reality is that at the at worst
case scenario
um there were a lot of numbers maybe in
1997 or eight that the the sponsor
mentioned but they've decreased
significantly to be virtually on
non-existent
um I don't think that um this bill is um
you know what's what's being written is
already uh it's already legal so I don't
I don't think we need to uh to legislate
so I'll be voting in opposition
thank you I think it's safe to say this
bill will not be going on consent
representative Prue
so with the information that
representative Stone just gave us I I
don't think I can support this anymore
and if I need to withdraw my second and
let somebody else do that I'd be happy
to
thank you
because if it's already illegal I don't
think we need the reason syringes I
think we'll just go for it then I don't
think this is necessary okay okay well I
we don't need to you don't need to
withdraw your second unless you want to
you just vote against it but I'm going
to vote against it okay that's fine
representative Newman
yeah I just have a question about the
discussion that we've been having here
some I just heard that it's legal for
minors to have needles in the state is
that correct
because the because the answer to my
previous question was that this bill
doesn't really have an effect because if
there's a
illegal substance in the needle whether
they are a
um whatever authorized agent or whether
they are just a juvenile
that has something that is contrary to
the prescription that they are
authorized to have they are then subject
to whatever the penalties are so I I
just don't see
what this law is going to do
representative Stone would you uh be
willing to read us that portion of the
statute
Mr chair that would be the portion of
the new language
no I mean the the one that um says that
it's it's currently legal for um for the
miners to possess a yes currently not
listed as being legal
but what it is is the testimony we heard
today of a uh say a diabetic parent
having a syringe there well I believe
the example was they were unconscious
there's competing harms defense and I
can't really Envision uh going through
the law enforcement process and
including going to judicial process of a
judge not using a reasonable
expectations that that would be a
competing harms defense
no but I I thought you said that it's
currently legal for everyone 2012 that
was the adults they decriminalized it in
2001 for adults the juvenile statue
again though you see if you have the
syringe and it's under the law I can't
really Envision many Law Enforcement
Officers taking action on that unless
there's an illegal substance in the
syringe itself which makes it illegal
okay so we're back to it it is currently
illegal just that it most likely will
not be prosecuted correct Mr chair
representative scitec I want good
legislation not uh prosecutorial uh
discretion
thank you representative Murray
thank you Mr chair
um I just want to bring it back to the
points made by reps Bolden and Howard
that you know even if representative
Stone you can't see like law enforcement
realistically enforcing these things
just having the opportunity to do so
still can leave a negative impact to the
public as mentioned by representative
Bolden and Howard just having charges in
and of itself can severely negatively
impact especially a child's life
um and I think that taking care of your
parent and this bill has been very clear
that it's about prescription drugs it's
not just needles in general I don't
think this brings any harm to children
and I will be sporting otd thank you I'm
representative here Catherine did you
um you can be an authorized agent and a
few of the young men on this team today
were authorized agents for family
members at young age so by law you can
do that but there's training that goes
with that
a lot of training from what I understand
so for any any parent or anyone that
feel they want their child to do to to
be their authorized agent can do that
today
so for me I don't know why we have the
bill here do you know what that statute
is that would authorize authorizations
so we can look it up yeah if there is
such a statute I think that would have a
bearing because that would make this
duplicative
um representative Bolden
I'm just wanting to provide some input
on the whole discussion over whether or
not it is illegal the bill
has the RSA that says that it's illegal
to furnish
hypodermic syringe to a person under 18.
that's the part of the law that's being
edited by this bill so it says
the law currently says now no person
shall sell furnish or give to any person
under 18 years of age an instrument
commonly known as a hypodermic syringe
hypodermic needle or any other
instrument adapted for the
administration of drugs by injection
and so the bill scratches a bunch of
that out and then adds unless the
recipient is acting as an authorized
agent for another as defined in RSA 318
colon 42.
so I don't know if that's obvious to
anyone else but it seems obvious to me
that the intent of the bill is to
maintain that it is illegal for minors
to access syringes that are not being
used for medical purposes
thank you and for pointing out the
obvious as we did not look at it
um so yes the current state of affairs
is it is illegal to give a minor a
syringe and this bill would just carve
that out and say unless they are an
authorized agent and this is the only
place in statute where that is dealt
with so I do not see the harm in in
carving that out I think
go ahead and representative Newman I
also don't see the the harm in carving
that out because it protects the
authorized agent now from the
possibility of being arrested because
it's carved out if in fact they're an
authorized agent and if in fact there is
no illegal substances in the and and it
may may be as representative Stone said
that even if there is they're not going
to be arrested or not but I think this
gives specifics where people might be
get a benefit from having the miners
available to help them with their
prescription drugs
and where they you would take away for
that authorized agent the possibility of
being uh in con having to be in contact
with the criminal justice system
okay I think we've pretty much beat this
up pretty good
um I would ask the clerk to call the
roll at this point the motion on the
floor is ought to pass
thank you Vice chair Rhodes yes
representative Pratt no representative
scitec
representative Prue price yes
representative janvin yes representative
Manion yes representative Reed yes
representative Stone no
representative tanzar yes
representative goth right no
representative muse no representative
Bolden yes
representative Bradley no
representative Murphy no representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
Howard yes representative vote Yes
chairman Roy
cheer votes yes motion passes fourteen
six
okay so House Bill 397 passes fourteen
to six it will not be on consent and who
was going to do The Minority Report
representative Stones volunteering
chair I'm sorry if I may be
the recommendation that you would have
with that I will close the public
hearing on HP 397. excuse me the
and I will open the executive session on
hb305
relative to the options for violations
who was that
I think it was town so I can see
representative was this the subcommittee
that you did
uh thank you chairman yes it was and do
you have a motion you'd like to make on
the bill uh we had a motion of itl okay
it means I speak to your motion yes
thank you chairman well this bill did
have good intent uh it was a bill that
took a lot to pass last year if this was
amendment 2 I believe
1778 I may have the incorrect uh House
Bill uh but the intent of this was to
increase the
level of violation from a violation to a
class a felony we thought the amount of
time and effort that it took to even
squeeze by the bill it passed last year
would almost be a slap into the face of
everyone who tried to work on this last
year so we think that at this time that
it should be ideal
I want to speak to your second
representative
representative tenzar could you help us
out um with regard to this bill just a
little explanation so this was a a very
confusing Bill to begin with and while
we were in the subcommittee speaking
with representative Manion he did do a
good job to try to explain it the best
he could but you may know Jim and Roy
this the bill that was passed last year
that I think uh Senator Abbas was the
Prime sponsor on that this went through
so many different committees Judiciary
and they got the best that they could
get and they think that if we tried to
introduce this that there's going to be
a problem going forward with all the
bills so we think that while it may look
like a good bill now it's too much to
put forward at this particular time okay
thank you
um so you know further discussion I will
ask the clerk to call the roll the
motion on the floor is inexpedient to
legislate
Vice chair roads yes
representative Pratt
yes representative scitec
representative Prue yes representative
Jan Finn yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenzar yes
representative gathright representative
Muse yes representative Bolden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman
yes the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes representative Howard yes
representative vote Yes
chairman Roy chair votes yes motion is
unanimous
um HP 305 in expedient to legislate I
hear my closing executive session open
the executive session HP 512
yeah
representative Jennifer did you have
something to
tell us about this bill
um HP 512
let me try turning on my microphone
there we go uh you should have before
you Amendment zero six zero five H
um and oh you have to have the
underlying bill in front of you this is
going to
if you go to page two of the original
bill
line a page two line 13 through line 24
this will remove that entire section
and as you see in the amendment that is
going to renumber 159 F5 as F4 because
F4 is being eliminated the one that
deals with penalty so
accessories manufactured in New
Hampshire to be sold in New Hampshire
without any federal oversight as long as
they never leave the state of New
Hampshire it's not considered interstate
commerce
Mr chair if I make we just have a maybe
everyone in five minutes just get your
bills
all right we're going to restart the
executive session
on hb512
and I'm going to recognize
representative Jamber for a motion
I move o2p on Amendment zero six zero
five
would you like to speak to your motion
representative chairman on the uh
Amendment yes thank you Mr chairman
um the basic tenant of this bill is is
not to punish our police officers our
law enforcement in the state of New
Hampshire
uh
or remove them from Office what we would
like to do is to recognize that under
the entire State Commerce Clause of the
United States Constitution that a
something is manufactured in the state
of New Hampshire sold in New Hampshire
never leaves the state of New Hampshire
is not subject to Federal oversight and
represented yep representative would you
like to speak to you a second
sure I tend to agree that an officer may
be
put in a position where he has to act on
them and to penalize him for doing his
job I don't agree with
representative Pratt
so I don't believe in penalizing police
officers maybe from an office uh they
may have an order from somebody higher
up and they have to follow the order
but what what teeth are now left in this
bill is there any teeth left in this
bill
yeah that again the basic tenant of the
bill was to make it so that New
Hampshire recognizes as a policy that
something made and sold in the state of
New Hampshire never leaves the state of
New Hampshire is not subject to Federal
oversight
okay thank you
so to be clear
um it's your intent that this bill is
actually more of a policy statement
than um anything with actual teeth
correct that is correct thank you
further discussion
representative Stone
thank you Mr chair I'd also like to
point out that a similar bill was passed
Texas house bill number 957's passing
2021 that expressly exempts Federal
Regulation firearms
that are made in a state from being
entered into Commerce as well
and was that Bill signed in the law in
Texas
how do I say this um I think that
this to say that
you can't
um
everything that's manufactured here must
stay here how do you know that because
once I purchase once I purchase
something I can do what I want
that's a reality
I can try to answer that if you'd allow
me to
just let's stick to the amendment first
okay okay yeah
um then we can represent Muse on the
amendment yeah on the amendment I will
uh I will vote to support the amendment
uh
it makes a bad Bill uh slightly better
and that's never a bad thing so uh I
thank you
um that allows the court to call the
role in the amendment the uh emotionless
to adopt Amendment zero six zero
zero six zero five h
chair roads
representative Pratt
no
representative scitec
representative Prue yes representative
chandrin yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tenzai yes
representative Guthrie yes
representative Muse yes representative
Bolden yes representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
Howard yes representative vote Yes
chairman Roy cheerable cheers motion
passes 19-1
okay at this point the amendment is
adopted representative Jamber would you
like to make a motion yes Mr chairman I
move
ought to pass as amended for Hospital
512.
second
Ed by representative pru representative
jambrian would you like to speak to your
motion on the underlying bill
absolutely once again the the bill as
amended would allow
an item manufactured in the state of New
Hampshire sold in New Hampshire and
remains in New Hampshire and I I can
explain that to the question of the
representative earlier
um to to not be subject to that we
acknowledge it is not subject to Federal
oversight and by that I mean I'll give
you two examples uh again as I've stated
many times in committee I served the
last two summers working in a camp
setting Where I Was A I am a Firearms
instructor teaching youth to safely
utilize firearms and one of the problems
that we've realized early on was that
the ear protection
uh was not suitable for a youth it's
made for an adult and therefore the
youth were actually exposed to high
levels of noise
the whole idea purpose is to reduce harm
reduction in the ear protection so
utilizing a suppressed firearm would be
in the best interest of those Scouts I
shouldn't be using the word Scouts for
those youth
and that this bill would allow
a suppressor made in New Hampshire
sold or donated to the camp to be
utilized in the camp setting and never
leave that camp without any federal tax
uh being against the camp the second
situation would be
a Firearms School where they have a
range an indoor range and I can think of
at least four of them that I know of in
the state of New Hampshire where the
person that owns that range
could go to a manufacturer that makes a
suppressor
purchase that suppressor have it on the
Range and it never leaves the range and
it would not be subject to the federal
tax so that's basically what this bill
is trying to do is to acknowledge that
if it's made in New Hampshire sold in
New Hampshire and remains in New
Hampshire it is not subject to Federal
oversight
I hope that answered the
representative's question well if it did
it didn't answer for me I'm I'm curious
how does this how do you keep
in other words so the representative's
point if I purchase if I go to Zig and
buy a gun from them directly because
they're manufactured here in New
Hampshire how does the law contemplate
me moving to Florida with that and thus
bringing into interstate commerce
um
you can't
representative
isn't there something with full faith
and full faith and recognition Clause of
the Constitution if you get married in
Connecticut you're married in New
Hampshire so if you had bought this
legally had it all done here legally
you're not doing any Commerce you're
transporting your personal property to
Florida so
I don't like the you know never mind
I've said it
representative Stone in the case of
firearms it would be similar to uh
you're required by ATF to manufacture it
with markings saying that it was
manufactured in the state of origin and
your manufacturer's name that you're on
file with uh generally some states do
not allow suppressors so if you were to
move to a state that specifically by
state law prohibits them you would not
be allowed to bring your personal
representative Newell
um just a point of clarification on on
that
um
is that a Federal Regulation
which part for it to be labeled that
it's made in New Hampshire yes that's a
requirement of marking variants through
ATF and all firearm manufacturers are
required to do that by federal law right
but if I'm not mistaken what this bill
says is that these things would not be
subject to Federal Regulation so would
they be subject to that Federal
Regulation to be labeled you would not
be able to manufacture it without a
so you'd have to comply with it
but you're not entering into Commerce
but what this Bill is saying is that
that things that are made here are
exempt from Federal Regulation and
you're saying that a Federal Regulation
would ensure that it's labeled that way
yeah just follow-up clarification most
manufacturers will sell their products
uh to other members in different states
that therefore you're taxed on that
based on how many units you you make
individually and there's a reporting
element at the end of every year where
in April you have to fill it out so at
the end of the day
if you're manufacturing it it's marked
where it's made
and if you're entering into Commerce
you're taxed accordingly if these are
subject I believe not to be taxed if
they're going to be residing in New
Hampshire and not entered into Commerce
if you look at page two line 10 through
13 I'm sorry 10 through 12.
the state law would be a firearm
manufacturer sold in New Hampshire under
this chapter shall have the words made
in New Hampshire clearly stamped
inscribed or otherwise marked on the
central part of the firearm such as the
receiver refrain so
representative Muse and then
okay well I appreciate the removal of
the penalty uh penalty part of the of
the of the bill uh I think there are
some other things that we need to be
very much aware of
during our conversation one is I
understand that the the new intention of
the bill is really to serve more as a
policy statement in New Hampshire but
the reality is is this would do
something that HB 1178 which we've
passed last year did not do which is I
would write nullify federal law in New
Hampshire
the courts have consistently ruled uh
that nullification laws are not
constitutional when States pass them
Missouri's law which is different from
the one we passed last year but similar
in some ways was actually found
unconstitutional last week
um one of the ways uh that uh folks
treaded around that issue uh in in 2022
uh in New Hampshire uh was to take
advantage of some earlier Court rulings
uh that that basically
uh said that uh the federal government
couldn't commandeer State resources so
uh one of the reasons why uh that
particular bill passed the muster of the
Attorney General was because it wasn't
likely to be immediately overturned by a
court
another issue that I see is it's
extremely broad if you look at the bill
it encompasses Springs screws nuts and
pins you're going to need a pretty small
stamp to stamp made in New Hampshire on
on some of those things the other thing
is what is to prevent somebody in China
from stamping made in New Hampshire on a
firearm and claiming the protection of
New Hampshire law how do we have any way
of really knowing uh where a firearm is
from
perhaps some of the in-state
manufacturers can prove it maybe not it
makes it very difficult to enforcement
to enforce it one of the issues that
comes up with a lot of the laws and
proposals that we we discuss is well how
how would it be enforced
I don't know
how would it how would it be enforced
it's a policy statement so when it
whenever a bill is framed as a policy
statement it almost infers that it
really doesn't matter how it's enforced
which which tells me maybe this
shouldn't be a bill it should be more of
a house resolution which is uh what the
folks who had the house resolution uh in
the one of our previous session days on
urging Congress to ban assault weapons
we're trying to do
um the other thing and the last thing
that I'll point out is I think there's a
difference between supporting
a constitutional right and creating
special rights
um and I think that if we pass this bill
we actually kind of cross the line when
it comes to that so it just urge there's
just a lot of reasons to sort of slow
down on this one and I would just urge
my colleagues to maybe take a step back
and and take another look at it thank
you representative Bolden
thank you um I don't think I was present
for the hearing on this bill and I was
wondering if anyone recalls whether any
manufacturers
working in New Hampshire gave testimony
because I've found an interesting um to
hear that Texas
uh passed a similar bill and I just
tried to find it Google this was the top
search result this is not selective
Googling but in this article they're
saying that it was passed in 2021 and as
of January 2022 when this was written
the manufacturers in Texas were pretty
frustrated because it was affecting
their ability to have out-of-state sales
in some way and I'm not going to claim
to understand anything about this
industry
um but I guess it's because
if
the manufacturers
worked in state the ATF said we're going
to impose
um sanctions anyway and they and they
didn't care and then the state law said
well ATF we're going to put you in jail
um and then the ATF said well that's
fine because we just won't let you run
your operation outside of the State of
Texas and so it's been a Tit for Tat
thing
um that's kind of seems to have resulted
in a Stranglehold on the silencer or
suppressor manufacturers in Texas and as
of this January 2022 article
they're waiting for the law to be
changed and they're not happy with the
result that they got and I thought that
it would be worth throwing that info out
there
thank you uh I actually
um I'm tending to agree I I don't see
um Zig zauer who
has a billion dollar contracts providing
weapons to our military and selling
Firearms around the world would limit
themselves by engaging in this where
they have the potential to lose billions
of dollars of business
um by not being able to ship their
firearms out of state because of a few
suppressors sold here
um representative Rhodes thank you Mr
chairman
I I may be looking at this wrong and
I think that there there has to be a
level of standard on anything that is
that is made
and
the concern that I'm having is you know
if you use a product
incorrectly you know then that's just
the product if I use my pen wrong it's
not it's not the manufacturer of the
Pen's fault if I use my opinion
correctly however if there's an if there
is a defect with a product
I don't you know we wouldn't tell a car
manufacturer that if their seat belts
weren't you know properly installed that
that the user is at fault
um so again I may be looking at it
differently or not understanding it but
I
I have concern with it
I don't could you follow what do you
what does it have to do with defects I'm
confused
um
so let me go back and read it because I
was
my understanding was that the testimony
they were talking about
The Testament that was given was was
about
um
they were talking about them not having
to be if they want to make manufacture
in in New Hampshire it didn't have to
have the same standard as
as something else you'd have to follow
the same roles
however that was a long time ago but
those are the notes that I have written
down so in representative James looking
at me with crazy faces but that's what I
wrote down so I'm not really sure where
I'm
representative Jennifer do you have any
response I don't I didn't see anything
about that
um well first I think what
representative Rhodes is trying to say
is if we're taking away the standard
then there could be defects and stuff
that are not going to be addressed um
maybe I'm misinterpreting that but I
feel like
uh your intent representative Jan Wren
was it sounds like more of the taxes
rather than the regulations and the
standards of how these weapons are
manufactured so is it possible that we
could get an amendment that would
clarify language in the bill or like
retain it so you could amend that
language and make it more pertinent to
quite frankly
if we were to go in and strip every
single thing except for the number one
definitions and two
line 17
through 20.
that was the only thing that this this
committee decided to pass I'd be happy
as I think it would cover the situation
thank you Mr chair at the heart of this
bill just like in Texas it's an issue of
uh taxation that is what it boils down
to is taxation by the federal government
on requiring 200 tax to have to be paid
for any suppressor or uh NFA item uh
Texas's uh Bill if you actually read the
bill is actually a lot more
comprehensive than what's been presented
here
based on the e-reading of that bill do
you feel like this bill would benefit
from a more comprehensive uh look at it
or
if we wanted to clean the bill up I
I'll withdraw my motion of otpa if if
you want to retain
ER
and I just want to comment I I I'm not
sure that I agree with the routine but I
do I if I look at the definition in the
first paragraph it has bump stocks in it
now I I don't I've forgotten whether
they're illegal or not or presidential
ladder or but they happen to be in there
um bump stocks are are actually legal
again I believe
after a short hiatus
representative um scitec I'd like to see
retain because look for me what's at
this bill
in this bill is it's it's a stalking
horse for the overreach of the federal
government
and the over the elastic clause and
everything that's
that I dislike about the federal
government and we're not able New
Hampshire to put our thumb effectively
in the eye of a beat
um
the federal government so as much as I
would like to do this symbolic gesture
it's useless and I just as soon have it
retained and walk out the back door
because we're not going to really win
anything
representative James would you like to
uh withdraw your motion about to pass I
will and representative pru would you
withdraw your Motion in a second you
betcha representative Jan Wren would you
like to make a new motion Mr chairman I
moved to retain house bill 512. and I'll
second now
I think we've had enough discussion
um or I'll ask the clerk to call the
role on retention of HP 107
. Mr Rhodes yes
you said 107.
no
representative scitec
representative Pooh
representative janvin yes representative
mannion yes representative Reed yes yes
representative Stone yes representative
tanzar yes representative Catherine
yeah representative Muse
yes representative Bolden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman
yes the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes representative Howard
yes representative vote Yes chairman Roy
cheer box yes motion passes 19-1
the bill is retained
and I hereby close the executive session
on House Bill 305.
and I opened the executive seven on
House Bill 107.
representative Manion would you like to
make a motion
yes thank you Mr chairman I make a
motion uh ought to pass on amendment
-0586h I passed out a copy of that to
everybody this morning
by representative Rhodes
representative Manning would you like to
speak to your motion on the amendment
yes thank you Mr chair uh this amendment
uh came out of uh subcommittee we did
extensive work on this I thank the group
uh what this amendment does is
uh addresses the concerns we had
initially with this bill being overly
Broad and also putting a giant burden on
the employer as opposed to the employee
so I think we've addressed those
essentially the loophole that we're
looking to close or that the response
was looking to close was Regis
registered sex offenders employing
minors or supervising minors or having
direct one-on-one uh alone contact or or
work with a minor and he mentioned the
landscaper scenario and I believe that
this this this new language addresses
that and then in addition it removes the
part where it would require the employer
to have a background check for all
employees and that would be overburden
for you know fast food restaurants or if
you have 10 separate
applicants for a job for one job you
have to get 10 separate background
checks so it eliminates that portion
altogether which is not part of the
representative priv would you like to
did a great job
further discussion
representative Bolden yes representative
I also want to piggyback on that that um
we looked it up and child care
facilities are already required by law
to do background checks so by
eliminating
um that part of the bill with the
amendment
um that required background checks we're
not making it so that nobody has to do
them there's already a bunch of
businesses that are required by allowed
to do them in other areas the law
um and it seems like those are
appropriate we don't need to do it too
the entire State and um also the
um I thought it's worth mentioning that
the handouts that we got during the
hearing for those specific situations
the guy who was a landscaper
his case was overturned because so like
he um he was he was initially convicted
of violating the law that requires him
to
um not have a job that involves children
this law and then the conviction was
overturned because the court very
specifically said that it didn't make it
at least we had never made it illegal
for us a registered sex offender to hire
a minor and so that's what the that's
the loophole that the sponsor was
originally trying to close and I think
along the way with the changes in the
wording in the amendment we also
addressed the conversation about like
being an employee but having Authority
in the workplace over a minor and coming
back to like the way that the law is
structured
um it's the responsibility of the
offender and not the employer and it
always has been
um because it's just too much for
employers every sex offender knows
they're registered
and it's their job and they know that
it's their job to make sure that they
don't enter certain types of employment
and the agency that manages them would
communicate these changes in a lot of
them so I don't know if that's helpful
information anyone but I think it's a
pretty solid Amendment and um
and I know that there's buy-in from
everybody who was really gung-ho either
way on the bill initially
that was very helpful thank you I know
that there were a couple different
factions going into that competing and I
think that they seem to have merged and
found a way to do it representative Muse
you know just wanted to say that um an
amendment like this is one of the
reasons why the legislature occasionally
Works
um so we actually passed a very similar
bill in the house last year HB 408 that
had some problems and I think we kind of
knew it had some problems when we sent
it over to the Senate
and the Senate thought it had so many
problems that they sent it to interim
study where it was never actually
interim studied
um
so so addressing some of the issues like
the background check issue addressing
the broadness of the bill that was
probably problematic in HP 408 is a is a
good thing
I think it's important that we put a
pretty bright line between people who
are child sex offenders and children and
what what the bill and what this
amendment do is they do that the other
the last thing I wanted to point out in
the spirit of maybe having a little fun
with a very serious bill is this
amendment may be putting the single
longest sentence in New Hampshire
statute into law
so if you actually do a word count on
that long long sentence it's 141 Words
which is somebody who's a I'm a big
advocate of plain language
so it bothers me
um but trying to dissect it and put it
back together in a way that addresses
that issue I think would cause more
problems than it solves so
congratulations maybe on on having done
something that no one else has done with
this amendment has anyone called
now I want to pass it just because of
that
um any other discussion uh
representative scitec
uh the problem I this it's it's fine
it's great but problem that I have and
it's one we should think about is the a
sex offender does this person wear The
Mark of Cain if he opens it I did this
when he's 26 years old and opens a
landscape business when he's 56 is he
carry that Mark forever and I just
uh it's not enough to sink the ship but
I don't like it I think that that
particular
particular aspect is actually important
but I think it's addressed in in another
statute as far as how long they have to
be a sex offender itself
I think that's where we should if that
needs fixing that's where it would be
done
um who had their hand up representative
Murray
um I was just hoping to get some
clarification on
does this amendment cover
all kinds of sexual offenders
um just because I I do agree with the
point brought up by my colleague
representative scitec um you know you
can get on the sex offender list for you
know
peeing outside or being on the beach
topless or I you know there are even
cases of minors getting charged as
sexual offenders just for like having
been undressed around other minors
um and there are severe severe severe
issues with our sexual offender
um
um registry list and how it affects
people for the rest of their lives
um and yeah I'm just concerned about how
this could make it harder for someone
who may not even have a victim to get a
job
um
I'll let the sponsor or I'll let
representative Manion address that I
would just again what I said to
representative scitec I think that's a
valid point and it's one that if a
representative has concerns about then
we would look at or they should look at
the statute that classifies sex
offenders and for how long and such this
bill just discusses with someone who's
already been put in that bucket whether
they belong there or not so um I don't
think that this bill addresses the
underlying whole concept of who is a sex
offender and how long they have to be
registered I think that needs to be done
in another bill representative Bolden
seems to want to say something
I can address that we talked about that
in the subcommittee and specifically we
talked about it with the representative
from the sex offender registry
Department here
um and uh it says the existing law if
you look at the the amendment
um you know existing law is in regular
font for the new people
um and it says a person's guilty of a
class a felony if
uh this is line eight on the first page
having been convicted in this or any
other jurisdiction of a felonious
offense involving child sex abuse images
or of a felonious physical assault on a
minor or of any sexual assault
um and so the there there's a lot of
weird and potentially dumb reasons to
end up on the sex offender registry sure
this does not apply to everyone it
applies to people who have violated
um in certain ways and um obviously it's
broad because we can't go updating this
every time we add a leader crime you
know
thank you representative Bolden for once
again pointing out the obvious that's
written in the bill in front of us
I don't know what we would do without
you today representative Manion thank
you Mr chair and just quickly that that
language is current language see this
bill only addresses
the who and what not not the actual
underlying offenses so that language is
in the bill I mean in the laws it is
currently and that wasn't addressed at
all
okay at this point I'm going to ask the
clerk to call the role on the amendment
this is um
to adopt the amendment
Vice chair Rhodes yes representative
Pratt yes representative scitec
representative Prue yes representative
chandrin yes representative Manion yes
representative Reed yes representative
Stone yes representative tanzar yes
representative kathry yes representative
Muse yes representative Bolden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman yes the clerk votes yes
representative Newell yes representative
Howard yes representative vote Yes
chairman Roy terrible yes motion is
unanimous the amendment is adopted um
representative Manuel would you like to
make another motion yes thank you Mr
chair I make a motion that we ought to
pass
um House Bill 107 as amended
second second about representative
Rhodes
representative would you like to briefly
just uh speak to this one more time
yes as I said I think this amended bill
now addresses all of the concerns and
issues we had with the overly broad
initial bill it was worked on by both
the sponsor and uh representative who
oppose the language they worked on it
together I think it's a great uh
a great Bill put together and uh even
though it has the longest sentence
yeah as I said I I want to pass it just
because of that now
um any any other further discussion I
think representative Bolden one more
overturned that conviction is
Representative Bob Lin and he agreed so
when I when I'm saying the person wrote
the opinion I'm saying the person who
overturned that conviction saying that
our laws were insufficient is a current
rep and he's the one who came in here
and we're seeing you had concerns about
the way the bill was written and he
signed off on the amended version thank
you and for uh Representatives who don't
know Representative Bob Lin was the
former Chief Justice of the New
Hampshire Supreme Court
yeah until we forced him out with a law
that said he was too old
um but he is an excellent source of
information so
um having said that did you have
represent scitec I'm not convinced that
this uh that the
sex offender ever expires but it's not
enough to stop this bill or to ask for a
carve out for this so I I just want to
jump up and down and that's enough
thank you we appreciate that
um and uh I agree that the sex offender
registry uh probably does need a lot of
work and if anybody wants to sponsor
legislation uh for next year let's talk
about it
um did you have something you want to
say yeah with that I'll ask clerk to
call the roll ought to pass as amended
scitec representative who yes
representative Jan Finn yes
representative Manion yes representative
Reed
representative Stone yes representative
tanzar yes representative Catherine
representative Muse
yes representative Bolden yes
representative Bradley yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Newman
the clerk yes
the clerk votes yes representative
Newell yes representative Howard yes
representative vote Yes chairman Roy
cheerals yes motion is unanimous
the bill passes unanimously
and representative uh Manion you'll be
doing the majority report
um representative Rhodes is going to
tell everybody what we have before we
leave I'm going to close the executive
session
and you're going to tell a bit about the
reports um just before um real quickly I
want to congratulate everybody on a
great job we did yesterday as a
committee even the ones of us who are
against each other we gave dignified
professional debates and even if you
lost the committee one because it was us
against each other so it was upsides
everywhere to that and it's been great
working with you guys for the first half
we're going to be taking a break after
this
one two weeks I don't know until I get
something from the Senate so um we'll be
recessing at the call of the chair so
whenever I get something I'll let you
guys know when we need to be back one
more item um I'm working out a day to
visit the court and I sent that out to
everybody where we can go over there and
they're going to serve us sandwiches or
something and the judge is going to talk
to us and I think it should be
informative
I think
did you resolve all of the whether it's
on consent or not I this last one I
don't know whether you said anything
about it
um is unanimous so um has anyone object
to consent in the last one I have no
objection to consent I don't hear any
Okay so
all right so representative Rhodes is
going to tell you if you have a report
due for today
well thank you Mr chairman okay so uh
going down the list House Bill 287
representative Reed
that was on consent 20 to nothing
um
representative Roy House Bill 397 uh was
14-6 representative Stone uoa a minority
report for itl
representative tenzar uh House Bill 305
which was itl also is 20 to nothing
in so everybody's aware we did withdraw
the motion for the Austin pass as a
ought to pass Amendment for house bill
512. in representative Manion you owe
for House Bill 107 again it was 20 to
nothing
on consent I need those reports by the
end of the weekend please because next
week is the deadline so I don't want the
clerk chasing me down
yeah that's next Friday isn't it
Thursday yeah so I need him I need him
by the end of the weekend please